if you love Riverdale as much as we do
you'll be happy to know that there's a
spinoff series coming your way
Katie Keene is set to star one of the
coolest cats in town so watch until the
end to find out which Riverdale
character will be moving to the Big
Apple what to expect the Television
Critics Association press tour left us
with our mouths wide open and no we
weren't trying to catch any flies
instead we were stunned to hear that The
CW will be coming out with a brand new
drama d that is a lot in common with
Riverdale the spin-off is set to air
sometime in 2020 but a concrete date has
yet to be set so for the time being
we're left with more questions than
answers but by the end of this video
you'll be up to date on everything the
CW has promised so far so what can you
expect from the recently announced TV
series Katie Keane
well great things no doubt however this
new show isn't going to be anything like
Riverdale according to Deadline magazine
the series will take place in a few
years after the Riverdale crew graduates
from high school so it's set to appeal
to both teenagers and young adults alike
instead of solving peculiar crimes and
getting into trouble the show will
follow for aspiring artists as they try
to make it big in New York City and
obviously though the show's leading
woman is going to be Katie Keene who is
a well known Archie comics character the
Riverdale universe is expanding like
wildfire so it was only a matter of time
before the show's director Roberto
aguirre-sacasa chose to take on a new
project and since the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina got snatched up by
Netflix Roberto had to set his sights
elsewhere Katie Keane is all about the
Performing Arts so expect there to be a
lot more musical performances than
showcased on Riverdale so now that you
know what to expect let's take a look at
how the spin-off will differ from the
original series the Cooper's are one of
the most respected families in river do
you sicko scumbags what not to expect in
a perfect world Katie Keene would
showcase all of our favorite for Verdell
characters unfortunately only one
character has been confirmed to appear
in both series so far but that doesn't
necessarily mean that other ones won't
follow Riverdale fans were super excited
to find out that Roberto was going to be
directing both series but their bubbles
bursts when it was confirmed that these
two projects wouldn't be crossing over
with each other but there's a good
reason for that since Katie Keene is set
in the future crossovers wouldn't make
much sense now would they
so while there might be a character
cameo or two down the line
the plots won't be feeding off of each
other and since Katie Keene takes place
several years after our favorite
Riverdale characters graduate from high
school we shouldn't expect teenage drama
to be the focal points of the show
although it would be super entertaining
to see what the Riverdale gang is up to
in their late 20s
the spin-off isn't going to focus on the
past instead it will highlight the
struggles of the modern-day artists now
let's find out who this mysterious Katie
Keene is we mean she must be pretty
special after all the show is named
after her all about Katie King at first
glance it's easy to mistake Katie for
Veronica and this has everything to do
with her big black hair but we can
assure you that these two divas have a
little in common
Katie was first showcased in Wilbur
comics number 5 which came out in 1945
although she was first as a secondary
character Katie was special enough to
receive her own comic book four years
later so it looks like history is sort
of repeating itself but this time she's
set to receive her very own TV show so
what makes Katie Keene so interesting
well for starters she's a real superstar
Katie is an actress a model and a singer
so she's a triple threat if we've ever
seen one for now Katie Keens role has
yet to be cast but something is
definitely in the works although the
pilot episode has been completed it's
yet to be confirmed if the series will
make it all the way to the finish line
the four stars when Katie's character
was first created
she was made to have a much younger
sister at first Katie's sister was named
sis the candy kid but before long her
name was revealed to be melissa melissa
is said to be a fierce redhead who was
constantly getting into trouble and
although she was originally 14 years
younger than Katie knew plots are in the
making in 1950 it was decided that
Melissa would become an older and more
prominent character and her name was
eventually changed to Mackenzie so she
might very well be one of the leading
characters in the series and since katie
is set to be about 26 years old and the
modern-day remake this places mackenzie
at roughly 20 years old
however mackenzie might be showcased as
a secondary character which would leave
room for Katie's rivals to enter the
plot so we're left to believe that
characters Gloria Grandville and Lucky
Lorelei might make an appearance
sometime soon
Gloria and luckier two wealthy models
who often pose as Katie's rivals however
their characters might get tweaked in a
positive way so we're led to believe
that Katie Gloria lucky and a mysterious
Riverdale star will be stealing the
spotlight
although Gloria and lucky are said to be
rude and spoiled this doesn't
necessarily mean that we won't like them
after all Sheryl blossom isn't the
nicest person in Riverdale okay your
suffolk serpent hands but she still
managed to win us over so who's to say
that the same won't happen with flora
and lucky a passion for fashion
Katy keen is known for being America's
queen of pin ups and fashions as a
matter of fact she was coined as such by
the Archie comics publisher unlike other
comic book characters Katy was hardly
ever seen wearing the same thing twice
so to make sure that Katie's wardrobe
was always on point readers were
encouraged to design her outfits so for
many years
Katie's fans submitted outfit drawings
to the publication and many of them were
chosen and displayed knowing this we're
certain that Katie's wardrobe is going
to be nothing short of spectacular and
since the series is based in the future
her closet might be jam-packed with
futuristic designs since the series is
said to showcase Broadway plays and
fashion shows we can only imagine that a
lot of the production's budget will go
into the costume making so if you love
glamor and everything that comes with it
Katie Keene might just inspire your
fashion sense after all
katie is sort of a trendsetter
where did you get all this information
Katy's look pinup girls used to be a
pretty big deal which is why many of
them are still remembered today one of
the most popular pinup girls who ever
lived was none other than Bettie Page
and let's face it she and Katy are
basically the same person but although
Katy is often referred to as a Bettie
Page look-alike her personality is
totally unique here's something you
might not know senior Katy Perry
basically stole Katy Keynes look but she
didn't get away with it
not only does Katy Perry resemble the
Archie Comics character but she's also
been accused of copying her fashion
sense when the internet found out that
Katy Perry had ripped off the character
people went wild with accusations so
during an interview with Rolling Stone
magazine the senior had this to say
I didn't base my life on an Archie
comics character funny enough the singer
later revealed that she also has a
younger sister with red hair so we're
not entirely convinced that KDP and Katy
K are so different after all and if you
believe otherwise just take a look at
these pictures and see for yourself so
are we the only ones who think that Katy
Perry should play Katy Caine because
let's face it she's the perfect girl for
the job
familiar faces so we're about ready to
reveal which riverdale character is set
to appear in the spin-off Katy keen and
it's none other than josie mccoy actress
Ashley Marie has already been cast in
the upcoming series and we're super
excited to see her live out her dream
josie is without a doubt the most
talented singer on Riverdale so it makes
perfect sense that she would want to
move to New York to become a star after
all Josie's talents would be wasted in
Riverdale and even though she might
enjoy singing in the basement of pop
small shop she can do much better no
offence Veronica here's something that
might shock you Ashley is actually 31
years old in real life so it makes
perfect sense that the actress is
leaving Riverdale to pursue a more
age-appropriate timeline however Ashley
looks so young that she could probably
pose as a high school student for the
next decade and no one would even notice
on another note it's very possible that
some of the Riverdale actors might one
day join the Katy Keene production
however this has yet to be confirmed
nevertheless we'd love to see Veronica
Lodge make a guest appearance on the
show and since Veronica originally hails
from New York this could very well
happen on top of that actress Camilla
Mendez who plays Veronica has stated
time and time again that she loves the
Performing Arts and since her fashion
sense dance moves and voice are nothing
short of stellar she would make a
fantastic Katie Keene character so if
things don't work out between Archie and
Veronica
perhaps the socialite will choose to go
back to her roots and expand her Empire
but we sure hope that these two
teenagers will come to their senses and
rekindle some time soon
Bizzaro del although we're sad to see
Josie go we can't wait to see her become
the next Diana Ross if you're all caught
up with the latest Riverdale episode you
probably noticed that Josie was hinting
towards wanting to start a new life sure
she might have grown up in Riverdale but
the town doesn't have the best
reputation knowing this Josie applied to
Juilliard which is located in New York
despite having an on-and-off-again fling
with a sweet pea
Josie sets her sights on Archie for a
change Josie asked Sweet Pea to
accompany her to her mother's wedding
but he declined her invitation because
she didn't want to make things official
between them so Josie ended up inviting
Archie instead and on top of that Archie
agreed to drive Josie to her Juilliard
audition unfortunately for her the
audition didn't go as planned which left
her feeling vulnerable so we're not
surprised at the bizarre Adele episode
ended with Josie and Archie kissing
unfortunately for them josie is set to
leave Riverdale at the end of season
three so their relationship is bound to
be short-lived despite the fact that
Josie's audition was a bust
we're sure that she's going to redeem
herself sometime soon and we have to say
that we're relieved because let's be
real Archie and Veronica belong together
who will be cast as Katie Keene by now
we all know that Katie Keene is going to
be a big hit but there are a lot of
things that have yet to be confirmed for
now the only existing cast member is
Ashley Murray
so we're not surprised to find out that
fans are getting impatient the Katie
Keene pilot episode and trailer is
currently being worked on so it's only a
matter of time before the rest of the
cast is secured the trailer will
premiere on Netflix sometime in 2019
however we don't expect the first scene
to air before 2020 but since the serie
is in high demand producers might work
extra hard to get
out as quickly as possible Katie Keene
is said to be a brunette who often dyes
her hair or wears wigs during
photoshoots so this makes it that much
harder to point a finger at anyone
before you go make sure you let us know
which three actresses would be a perfect
fit for Katie's character and if you're
right we'll make sure to give you a
shout out in our next Katie Keene video
and that's a wrap
don't forget to subscribe to the things
to be the first in line for the latest
news thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]